we're now at the stage of the 2024
presidential race in which we expect two
qualities of any new candidate one that
that candidate will be a Republican and
two that that candidate will be a fringe
afterthought since the GOP field is now
dominated by Trump and DeSantis but what
is strange about the newest candidate in
the race is that he has neither of those
things he's a Democrat and he hails from
the most prominent political family in
Democrat Politics the son of a slain
former presidential candidate and the
nephew of a slain former president is
running for president himself
here's why
this is what this is what happens when
you censor somebody for 18 years
[Applause]
they shouldn't have shut me up that long
because now I'm going to really let
loose on them for the next 18 months
they're going to hear a lot from me
what RFK Jr is talking about is how the
political establishment censored him for
questioning the safety of vaccines and
everybody especially conservatives used
to make fun of him for it until the past
few years when we've all seen firsthand
the corruption of the medical
establishment especially on vaccines
now he doesn't seem quite so crazy
and the corruption that RFK Jr is taking
aim at goes much deeper than just
medicine in his words quote I've come
here to today to announce my candidacy
for the Democratic nomination for
president of the United States my
mission over the next 18 months of this
campaign and throughout my presidency
will be to end the corrupt merger of
state and corporate power that is
threatening now to impose a new kind of
corporate feudalism on our country all
great points but surprising
surprising that this kind of message
might resonate especially surprising
that it resonates with Independence and
Republicans who until just recently were
the party of trusting the science and
defending big corporations it's
surprising how fast things can change
how parties can realign have priorities
can be upended and have the polls show
that this eccentric Kennedy could pose
an actual threat to Joe Biden I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael nols shook
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by my friends over at
good ranchers free bacon great meat a
secure price and an extra 20 off with my
code Knowles Canada w-l-e-s head on over
to goodranchers.com use my code Knowles
kwles for twenty dollars off your order
we will be getting to a really important
medical advice uh coming later today
it's going viral on Tick Tock which says
that losing weight is fat phobic you got
to follow the science you got to trust
the experts we'll get to that in a
second first though I I don't want to
just totally gloss over RFK Jr here we
have all spent so much time
kind of making jokes about RFK Jr
he has seemed outside the mainstream of
American political discourse until very
recently
now he's kind of a real guy
maybe he always was a real guy and and
what was wrong was the prevailing
consensus view we'll find out in his
campaign I guess but according to the
USA Today Suffolk poll
RFK Jr might actually have a shot at
least at making Joe Biden sweat
according to this poll Joe Biden right
now has only 67 support among Democrats
in the 2024 primary
Marianne Williamson who's the new AAG
dark psychic forces man candidate in the
race she has five percent
RFK Jr on his first day in the race
has 14 percent
that's pretty good RFK Jr is not one of
these guys who's been quietly and
steadily campaigning for president for
decades now
his candidacy kind of came out of left
field and he's already got a pretty
significant chunk of the Democrat
primary base
and what about the rest of the people
I'm no mathematician but 67 plus 14 plus
5 does not equal a hundred so that means
there's a huge portion of Democrats 33
percent of Democrats who just don't like
Biden who just like somebody else find
me anybody without the name Biden and I
will vote for that person
so it speaks to the weakness of Biden it
doesn't factor in Gavin Newsom Gavin
Newsom who clearly does want to run for
president he is currently campaigning
for president but he has said he will
not run if Joe Biden does and Newsom is
such an establishmentarian type guy he
probably probably would not run shows
there's a lot of dissatisfaction here
and when you've got a candidate with
real Democrat Bona fides he's not a fake
Democrat a dino a democrat in name only
this guy's a real Dem and his family is
is the major family in Democrat politics
and if this guy comes out and he runs
but he questions certain aspects of our
corrupt political establishment aspects
of it that are among the least popular
notably this merger of corporate power
with the prevailing ruling political
order
that could be effective
RFK Jr has so much working against him
he even has that speech impediment where
he kind of sounds a little bit like this
when he's campaigning and even with that
on day one you've got 14 not a bad
launch
people are so sick especially of the
medical corruption we're seeing more and
more evidence of that every day project
Veritas has just published some
undercover footage of a gender Clinic
that is contradicting what we've been
told by the liberal establishment we've
been told that they're not really
transiting the kids that's a right-wing
conspiracy theory that the only
transitions that are occurring happen
after 18 well that's not true a
multi-state investigation here has
exposed w p a t h w path connected
transgender Health doctors prescribing
puberty blockers to minors as young as
eight years old and irreversible
cross-sex hormones to minors as young as
14.
we do have patrons who are are as
starting as young as
eight nine we have a list of gender
affirming therapists that we can provide
too pediatric trans card definitely
exists they said it was transition or
suicide like I was given no choice I was
told you will kill yourself if you don't
go through with these treatments it's
very much for you know pro-hormone Pro
changes if you don't do this your child
will kill themselves that is the most
common theme I don't think anybody can
do that for a 10 year old
yeah I've just I've never done a 10 year
old yeah
so Messina Adolescent Clinic they start
at age 10. she did say this about like
surgery it's a way to go at this age age
10 would be something like a puberty
blocker when you then get to age 14 is
what I'll consider some you know
cross-gender hormones 14 is a reasonable
age was most kids are mature enough to
make a round informed decision
project very dust has these guys dead to
rights
and so two takeaways one the trans
activists are lying of course our
liberal establishment is lying of course
they are transiting the kids they're
putting these kids through very intense
treatments at hideously Young ages just
completely unacceptably young ages okay
we all knew that my second takeaway from
this is
project Veritas might survive
you remember there was the big split
with project Veritas because they booted
out their founder James O'Keefe now
James is doing his own thing and I'm
sure he'll be successful at that a lot
of people said okay there's no no point
in Project very task anymore if they're
going to lose James O'Keefe
this is good work
and
as someone who does not work for project
fairy toss or does not work for James
okey for that matter my only interest in
this entire thing is one that everybody
play nice we don't want to throw people
who've done a lot of help for the
conservative movement just out the
window but two the main thing I'm
interested in is
this investigative work this is very
very important work and so if project
Veritas can keep the hits coming like
that wonderful that's great news and
then if James O'Keefe in his new Venture
can keep his hits coming to all the
better if we can just expose these
people that is what we are after here
that is the end in sight we know
time and time again we have seen the
kind of corruption that they are
engaging in
just put it on camera just expose it
that sunlight is a great disinfectant
speaking of the trans Industry Colorado
has become
the first trans tourism state
there talk about things that the trans
activists probably want to hide
this is definitely among them they just
they're constantly preying on us they
are constantly going in they're trying
to to do anything they can to to tear us
down to to prevent them
from being exposed and so when we when
we engage in activities especially
online we're going to want to be very
clever about that we're going to want to
protect ourselves that's why you got to
check out expressvpn right now head on
over to expressvpn.com Knowles you've
heard me talk about how important it is
to have a VPN to protect your online
privacy choosing a VPN you trust is
equally important I like to research my
sponsors I only recommend brands that I
believe in I can say with full
confidence expressvpn is the best VPN on
the market expressvpn does not log your
online activity lots of cheap or free
vpns make money by selling your data to
advertisers but expressvpn developed a
trusted server technology that makes
their VPN servers incapable of storing
any data at all also expressvpn now uses
lightway a new VPN protocol they
engineered to make user speeds faster
than ever the last thing that really
sets expressvpn apart is how easy it is
to use you don't need any technical
skills to set it up you fire up that app
you tap one button to connect that's it
even your grandparents could do it even
I could do it and I'm a real Luddite
when it comes to this stuff not just me
saying in Business Insider The Verge
many other Tech journals rate expressvpn
the number one VPN in the world secure
your online data today by using the only
VPN that I trust visit expressvpn.com
Knowles get three extra months for free
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com Knowles
expressvpn.com Knowles to learn more
Colorado becomes the first transgender
tourism state
and what does that mean in practice it
means that in states around the country
it's now illegal to trans the kids
in states around the country what
project Veritas uncovered is not legal
anymore and so certain states are saying
oh if you're a young child who's a
little confused about your sex and
gender just come on over here yeah come
on over to Colorado and we'll pump you
full of hormones and set you on the path
to chopping off your genitals
oh you Hey listen parents you can't
abuse your children and sterilize them
and chop up their bodies in Tennessee
well come on over to Colorado we'll do
it for you over here
absolutely and if you've got those mean
old parents who won't do it well kids
hop on a Greyhound we'll take care of
you
I'm all for federalism
on certain issues you need a National
Standard
I think transgenderism certainly
transiting the kids but I think
transgenderism broadly is probably one
of those issues where we need a National
Standard I remember years ago when I was
a student I got to meet Justice Antonin
Scalia
and we asked Justice Scalia about
same-sex marriage which was being
discussed at the time and we
Sweet Summer children we were young
conservative students we said well Mr
Justice Scalia is it possible that we
just one state has gay marriage and
another state doesn't have gay marriage
and we just we just allow the states to
choose their own way and Scalia made an
important Point Scalia a defender of
states rights in so many areas said on
certain issues you kind of need a
National Standard what does it mean if
two men go to a courthouse in
Massachusetts and the judge says okay
you are legally married but then those
two men then travel to Tennessee and
Tennessee says two men can't get married
to each other marriage involves sexual
difference what are you guys talking
about
do they have the rights of married
people
marriage is the fundamental political
building block how do you have a country
if you've if you've got different
fundamentally different different
definitions of marriage in each state
but what's more fundamental even than
marriage
the definition of man and woman because
those definitions
are what build up marriage what is a
husband what is a wife so I just don't
see how we leave this issue to the
states
tranzing the kids of course because it's
it's just so deeply unjust we just feel
it in our very bones but transgenderism
broadly how do you have a country in
which men and women men and women means
one thing in Colorado but a different
thing in Texas
then we really agree on nothing to we
can have lots of diversity and variety
across the states but
if we're going to have a country at all
we have to agree on at least a few basic
things I don't see how we avoid this I
don't see how the Supreme Court avoids
weighing in on this sort of issue now
unfortunately the last time the Supreme
Court weighed in on a fundamental matter
they upended
the tradition of all of human history
and they and they denied reality when
they when they redefined
marriage and then later on the Supreme
Court even with apparently conservative
judges on it decided to redefine civil
rights protections for sex as civil
rights protections for gender identity
and sexual orientation so I'm not
exactly optimistic about about what
would happen if the Supreme Court were
to address this question today but
regardless
what else are we supposed to do
now we're going to live in a country
where we can't even agree on what a man
is and what a woman is that's not going
to work the libs for their part of
course are very much pushing a National
Standard
at the Biden Administration has just
been revealed to have sent an internal
email
this is from the Equal Opportunity equal
employment opportunity commission
warning that transgender people face
quote increasing attacks
and this email came out
just days after a transgender
identifying shooter targeted and shot up
a Christian school and killed three
little kids and three adults in that
school
apparently motivated by this gender
ideology according to the police but we
don't know for sure because the FBI
won't show us the manifesto wonder why
the FBI won't show us the manifesto
transgender identifying shooter
reportedly very likely motivated by the
gender ideology shoots up
poor little Christian kids in a school
and the Biden Administration says the
real victims here it's the trans people
always got to be whatever preferred
group the libs have identified even when
it is a member of that group committing
the crime that group still has to be
the victim no shame whatsoever
there's a political lesson here for
conservatives
which is we conservatives are very
moderate by our nature and moderation is
a virtue so I'm all for moderation but
I'm not for weakness and I'm not for
naivete
conservatives say well we can't push too
hard on the transgender issue let's just
focus on if it's if we should trans the
seven-year-olds or wait until they turn
eight Michael when you say we need to
eradicate the ideology of transgenderism
from public life that's too extreme it's
going to turn people off it's going to
turn people off do you ever think that
the libs promising to chop off kids
genitals do you think that don't you
think that's extreme don't you think
that might turn people off but the libs
don't care about that don't you think
that redefining marriage
regardless of your views on marriage
don't you think fundamentally redefining
the basic building block of society
might turn some people off the libs
don't worry about that
don't you think abolishing women's
bathrooms and abolishing women's sports
and don't you think that might turn some
people off
even forget about these these sexual
issues for a second don't you think
sending 100 million dollars to Ukraine
for a war that's not particularly
popular in the United States don't you
think that might turn people off don't
you think given what Americans think
about immigration that insisting on
taking in three million foreigners every
year one million legal immigrants and 2
million illegal immigrants don't you
think that's extreme and might turn
people off the libs don't care and it's
because the libs understand that while
it might be difficult to get a law
passed to get a new rule established
shortly thereafter people just adjust to
it the law is like the air
the law is just something that while it
very much shapes and defines the way
that we live
while it's it's part of our everyday
existence
people are not conscious of the law
we just we fight we argue oh no on the
conservative side we overrule Roe v Wade
and however this is the biggest fight
ever it's such a huge fight that
Liberals are going to try to assassinate
Justice Kavanaugh this is it is the
biggest fight ever in history and then
the Dove's decision comes out
and the Law changes and then most people
just kind of calm down about it it's the
water through which the fish swim
so the libs know if you can just change
that law if you can push through and
hold tight and actually get the job done
people will just adjust
that's what we need to do we need to
recognize yeah we're going to take a
little bit of a political hit right now
there the liberal establishment is going
to aim all of its fire at us but then
once we succeed
that's it it's just unconsciously shapes
people's lives now speaking of Standards
there are calls among Democrats and
especially among Republicans for an
elderly Democrat Senator to retire
and this elderly Democrat Senator she's
wrong about a lot of things and she's
said all sorts of terrible things she
has actually specifically targeted my
religious group this Senator when she
was grilling Justice Barrett when
Justice Barrett was first put up for one
of the lower courts she she said I don't
know if we can pick you justice Amy
Coney Barrett because you're Catholic
and the Dogma lives loudly within you so
I'm I'm not under any
Illusions about Senator
Dianne Feinstein's wisdom or judgment or
now that she's so elderly her ability to
carry out the basic functions of her job
but I am very much not in favor of her
retiring I am 100 on board with Dianne
Feinstein staying in that senate for as
long as she possibly can why we'll get
to it in a second first though
guys
you got to get good ranchers okay right
now go to goodranches.com enter promo
code and also if you've not changed the
way you buy meat yet you really need to
let me tell you three reasons I
personally subscribe to good ranchers
first good ranchers is giving you free
bacon for a year
pound and a half of bacon in every box
it's a 240 value second good ranchers
offers a price lock guarantee meaning
that when you subscribe your price does
not change for the lank of your
subscription when the price of meat is
expected to increase by another four and
a half percent in this coming year I
don't even understand how the financials
at good ranchers work but it could be a
huge huge savings for you and your
family third good ranchers meet is just
better it is just better objectively all
of the others they're all natural
burgers are sweet little elise's
favorite they're USDA prime steaks so
we're talking really top grade stake
here better than organic chicken it'll
change your standard for great meat I I
am very picky when it comes to my food
you know I'm an Italian extraction food
means a lot to us good ranchers is
second to none absolutely Peerless in
the space and the prices are better than
anybody too goodranters.com use promo
code nulls for 20 bucks off your box
free bacon great meat a secure price and
a bonus 20 off today promo code Knolls
at goodranchers.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered the what
corporations are erasing women they are
spitting on your values but instead of
just talking the problem away or
ignoring it Jeremy boring got proactive
when Harry's condemned us
all of you
he made Jeremy's razors when Hershey's
celebrated women with a man
Jeremy launched Jeremy's chocolate and
now that chocolate is here and shipping
as we speak
Jeremy's chocolate is free trade
delicious and comes in only two kinds
nuts and nutless
do you get it
do do you get it thanks to you we've
sold over 32 tons of it even though
Jeremy has a 300 bedroom house he
couldn't store that much chocolate so we
said you know what let's get a
fulfillment center and we did we told
you we were going to build a parallel
economy and we meant it Jeremy's maybe
the greatest joke ever told but it's
also very real and doing serious damage
to those web corporations that hate your
guts there are still a few bars left in
the first batch of Jeremy's chocolates
so get them before they're gone go to
Jeremy's
chocolate.com today
I am not in favor of Senator Dianne
Feinstein retiring
because then what happens
I can't believe I've seen conservatives
publish columns on this talk onto this
road Diane Feinstein she's almost 90.
she she has been home now she's been
home since February
and I she says it's because she's
recovering from shingles that may or may
not be the case but she's she's pushing
90. she did temporarily at least give up
her seat on the Senate Judiciary
Committee but she remains in the Senate
keep her there forever Dianne Feinstein
retires then what
then
the Democrats in California appoint a
much younger
more energetic more capable Democrat to
take her place
no thanks
Dianne Feinstein is very liberal but
Dianne Feinstein is
among the more conservative California
Democrats that are there
so what happens when she retires the
Democrats in California appoint a
certainly more radical more leftist
Senator to replace her no thanks
I say we keep her there
one of the sad facts about our Republic
these days is it's not governed in the
way that one who had read the
Constitution or watched Schoolhouse Rock
with the billup on Capitol Hill might
think that it is run
the government just kind of runs
itself
as a blob filled with bureaucrats and
all sorts of real legislating bodies
like the federal agencies that have very
little to do with what the people want
or with elections or or with the
Constitution or traditions for that
matter
so it just keeps keeping on the
Democrats when they were so terrified
that Donald Trump was going to destroy
the country we all knew Trump would be a
pretty good president but they said oh
no this is the end our country can't
survive and then what happened the
country did great the country did great
in part because of Trump's leadership
but the country was able to maintain
it's running in part because
the president doesn't totally matter
that was one of the things that
undermined Trump's ability to govern by
the way
same thing with the Senate what does the
senate really do
not all that much they do have some
specific power so I want to make sure
that the people who are in the Senate
are the most conservative people that we
can get
but the idea that oh no we need someone
who can respond urgently to any matter
that's not what the Senate does the
Senate is the greatest deliberative body
in the world most of what the Senate is
even supposed to do is just deliberate
you know you don't need to be terribly
energetic for that keep Dianne Feinstein
in her place speaking of dubious Signs
of Life
this is my favorite news story all week
maybe all month
you know there's a debate raging at the
daily wire
this debate
is over the existence of aliens on the
one side on the incorrect side you have
Matt Walsh
you have Matt Walsh and all the libs
who believe in E.T Little Green Men
it's very it's very hard for me to see
my friend Matt who is generally a wise
person
he is his head is basically screwed on
straight and he's just he's so wrong
about this then on the other correct
side of the bait you have me
and all of the conservatives and the the
people with proper judgment who
recognize that demons are tote I'm sorry
that aliens are totally fake that was a
that was a slit because what people say
are aliens are almost certainly demons
though that's a secondary aspect of the
debate which we can get to later
this this news story today that's so
important for this National conversation
we're having
comes from Elon Musk
who happens to agree
with me
a lot of people ask me you know
um where are the aliens and I I think if
anyone would know about aliens on Earth
that would probably be me I would think
yeah I'm like you know very familiar
with space stuff
um
and I've seen no evidence of aliens I'm
not saying that we are unique I'm simply
stating to the best of my knowledge that
there is no evidence for other uh
conscious life I I I I hope that there
is and I hope they're peaceful uh
obviously the two important
characteristics um but um we're just
saying we haven't seen anything yet so
there's no evidence
no I love this because Elon he's right
if anybody on Earth
would know about aliens it would be this
guy
my only hesitation actually
at celebrating that he's on my side of
the alien debate is that
Elon Musk is so impressive and eccentric
some have suggested he might be an alien
himself
and if he were an alien then denying the
existence of aliens is exactly the sort
of thing you would expect an alien to
say so that's my only little caveat here
but generally speaking I think that Elon
Musk is a human being I think he's very
very intelligent I think he has a unique
expertise on outer space
I'm glad that he agrees with yours truly
on the matter of aliens the thing that
gets me about the alien people
is that and by I'm not talking about a
hybrid of humans and E.T I'm talking
about the people who really believe in
aliens they always go back to this
ridiculous argument they say well the
universe is so big it's just probable
that there are other life forms out
there it's so big it's just
statistically probable that
that isn't true
that represents a fundamental
misunderstanding of probability and
statistics
because in order to know the probability
the statistical likelihood of something
we have to know something about the
thing that we're talking about we have
to know something about the thing whose
likelihood we're trying to predict and
when it comes to the origin of life
we don't
we do in the sense that God created Adam
and then out of his rib he created Eve I
think that's probably the most accurate
description of how life begins that we
can find and I'm sure some dork
scientist in a lab coat is going to say
well actually it was seven zillion years
ago there was this interaction of this
chemical with this other chemical and
that may or may not have some scientific
validity but it's just not a precise and
accurate way to describe it but but
furthermore we don't have any working
scientific theory of the origin of life
we just those lions with the lab goes
have no clue whatsoever so if you don't
know even the basic aspect of the thing
for which you're trying to determine
probability and statistical likelihood
then you've got nowhere to go
the universe could be a thousand times
larger than we estimate that it is
there is still not one shred of evidence
there's not one single reason to believe
that there is any additional life beyond
our Earth say well what do you do you
think that we're unique
yeah why not there's a lot more evidence
that we're unique than evidence that
we're not unique thank you Elon thank
you Elon for proving my point speaking
of aliens
will turn away from the aliens on Mars
for a second and turn toward the aliens
in Guadalajara president Trump has just
announced that he will use the military
to crush
the Mexican drug cartels
fentanyl heroin meth and other lethal
drugs are pouring across our wide open
border
stealing hundreds of thousands of
beautiful American lives and it's
happening like never before in our
history children are being left without
parents families are being ripped apart
communities are being decimated
our neighbors and fellow citizens are
having their entire worlds destroyed
destroyed like nobody thought possible
our country is being poisoned from
within by the drugs and by all of the
other crime that's taking place
the drug cartels are Waging War in
America
and it's now time for America to wage
war on the cartels
in this war Joe Biden is cited against
the United States and with the cartels
they are making more money than they've
ever made before times ten
president Trump goes on he's been making
a number of these policy videos it used
to be that a campaign would release a
50-page paper on here's my policy on
this or that but we live in an age that
is much more multimedia and we have we
have far shorter retention spans now so
I like these five-minute president Trump
policy videos
what he highlights here
is a correction to the way that
conservatives think about foreign policy
the way that foreign policy debates are
presented very often is a debate between
interventionism and isolationism
and what's curious about that
representation is that it splits the
conservatives because a lot of
conservatives think what why am I
spending 100 billion dollars potentially
sending American troops and into Ukraine
and maybe throwing us into World War
Three why would I do that and let's just
focus on our own borders but then there
are other Republicans who will say well
why are we letting some two-bit strong
man push us around we're the United
States of America We Are the World
Police and we're gonna we're gonna go in
maybe not build Nations but we're going
to go in and assert our strength and our
interests so which is it what's the
conservative
answer
just looking at ourselves and being
cowardly that doesn't seem conservative
but then going around and spreading some
wilsonian project of creating
democracies everywhere and raising the
pride flag in Kandahar that doesn't seem
very conservative either the debate is
not between isolation and intervention
the debate is over what kind of
intervention are we going to have
the idea that we're going to go spend a
zillion dollars to raise a pride flag in
Kabul
is crazy especially when you consider
that we're told we're not allowed to use
our military force to stop the actual
Invasion run by some of the worst
criminal organizations on the face of
the Earth that's going on at our
Southern border right now which has a
much more direct effect on our political
order the idea that we're going to send
hundreds of billions of dollars of
weapons and potentially some of our own
young men to go fight a war in Ukraine a
territorial dispute that's been going on
for a long time when we're not going to
take care of a territorial dispute on
our own Southern border that seems crazy
to a lot of people it's just as in the
debate over Free Speech the debate over
free speech is not between free speech
on the one hand and censorship on the
other it's a debate over what standards
what taboos what Norms are we going to
have the same thing is true here foreign
policy debate is not a debate between
intervention and isolation it's where
are we going to intervene and for what
purpose you know I've got a new
interview series it's called Michael and
quickly becoming one of our most popular
shows we've ever done in these
interviews we dive deep into a wide
variety of topics with Extraordinary
People for example
I interviewed a former astrologist who
struggled with thoughts of suicide and
looked to the Stars For answers I
interviewed an exorcist a priest father
Dan riehill who detailed the frightening
reality of possession as well as the war
raging in the Supernatural world this
week we released a new episode with
Joshua zakkoff a former DMT and magic
mushroom user who came to realize that
all that stuff was really terrible and
became a Christian what he told me will
shock you check it out I started getting
into DMT where I was having encounters
with light beings what did you think the
light beings were with acid and
mushrooms you don't typically at least I
never had visuals with the DMT this was
like full-on like that you're seeing a
whole world just crack open in front of
you what would they tell you these three
beings come in my room and another one
came in it was dragging my body and they
told me if you don't stop doing heroin
this is you
[Music]
this episode is available the rest of
the series is available now as well on
the Michael Knowles Show YouTube channel
go check it out after this show my
favorite comment yesterday is from Karis
Stewart who says if as the FDA contends
pregnancy is a disease what is IVF
more disturbingly if pregnancy is a
disease could we soon see coercive
sterilization campaigns in the name of
Public Health really great point because
the FDA in order to fast-track an
abortion drug they had to claim that
pregnancy is a life-threatening illness
when in fact it's the abortion drug that
is life-threatening because it kills
people you can't you can't actually
argue does anyone seriously argue that
pregnancy is a life-threatening illness
or a disease well if it is then what
about fertility treatments
you're telling me that fertility
treatments are also an important medical
service what do you talk fertility
treatments are just going to bring on
this life-threatening disease we got to
ban all of those right and and then to
your point on the potential coercive
sterilization
that did happen
it sterilization has happened in the
United States but we're seeing now
coercive sterilization of poor little
kids who by definition cannot consent
and who are being sterilized and having
their lives ruined by very
Wayward parents and this insane ideology
but then you look around at India you
look at China and there were direct
coercive sterilization campaigns that
took place as a result of a book by an
American Paul Air like's population bomb
which warned that within a decade this
was in 1970 within a decade we would
have mass famine because there were too
many people on earth it turned out to be
complete bunk over the last 50 years the
world population doubled malnutrition
fell to an all-time low but
these policies were implemented in India
where if people wanted access to
utilities if people wanted access to
basic necessities they would they would
have to sterilize themselves and in
China which had the one child policy
killed countless people over the years
could it happen here
a lot of people said a lot of things
couldn't happen here and look where we
are closing down churches our way of
life for three years
redefining the basic aspects of society
chopping off little kids genitals
that couldn't happen here a lot of
things are happening politics can change
very very fast
okay uh
I want to get to an important
aspect of our Public Health
and our are specifically Mental Health
Arena not transgenderism I know everyone
talks about transgenderism all the time
now this is more important this is
fat phobia this is trans slenderism if
you will a mental health counselor has
gone viral saying that if you are fat
and you lose weight
while you're fat phobic another great
question this person is asking if there
is any time in which intentional weight
loss is not fat phobic
9.9 of the times
if you are intentionally losing weight
it is fat phobic I'm leaving that point
a little zero one percent in case I am
truly truly wrong but I don't think I am
and here's the reason why I'm not saying
if you exercise
and happen to lose weight that that is
fat phobic
I'm not saying if you start a medication
and you happen to lose weight that is
fat phobic I am not saying that if
you're going through any type of take a
drug causes you to illness and I'm not
saying that's that altering your body in
some way that that is fat phobic I'm
saying when you are intentionally
exercising to lose weight altering your
diet to lose weight doing any activity
intentionally to lose weight is fat
phobic I still can't get over if you
take a pill and you go through a medical
treatment that causes you to start
wasting away I guess I won't blame you
for that I guess that's not totally your
fault but if you ever want to lose
weight so that you are less obese so
that you're healthier why
that is fat phobic the irony is that the
people who accuse others of phobia
are always the ones denying rationality
a phobia is supposed to be an irrational
fear but it's the ones who accuse people
of a phobia they're the ones who deny
rationality I don't even just mean that
they are unreasonable they're obviously
unreasonable people but I mean they deny
even the possibility of rationality
because I can make a rational argument
and say well when when you're morbidly
obese that can have all sorts of
terrible effects on your health and it
also is spiritually disordered if you've
got a problem with gluttony you probably
are going to want to address that
problem and so in order to be physically
healthier
to become more spiritually disciplined
to not hoard resources for yourself even
to to
have a more healthy relationship with
the physical world
um you should lose weight
they say how dare you
or if what about the transgender phobia
what if I make an argument and I say
that look I'm using my reason and I
think men and women are different and I
don't see how your true identity could
differ from your natural biological sex
and when you look at the rates of
depression and anxiety and suicidality
after the so-called transgender
reassignment surgery actually none of it
improves and on one measure according to
the largest data set on this ever on
anxiety things actually seem to get a
little bit worse and so for that reason
for many many other reasons which are
philosophical which are anthropological
which are biological which are
psychological for all of these reasons
transgenderism does not appear to be
true
and they would say how dare you how dare
you bring up reason and logic they they
are the ones who deny any recourse to
reason because what but what they say
when you ask them for a logical argument
for their beliefs
is they say well there doesn't need to
be a logical argument
because it's just my subjective feeling
when you propose a debate like we did
two days ago at the University of
Pittsburgh the very last minute even the
top Scholars on this stuff are going to
drop out they're going to drop out
because
the real the real phobes the real people
who are being irrational here and who
are they're phobic even of rationality
itself they are they are the libs that's
what they do
now another viral Tick Tock I do want to
get to before we go this would be uh a
black lady who really doesn't like white
people can you imagine here's why I
don't trust white people I don't trust
white people for a multitude of reasons
but one of the main reasons is they're
unpredictable like I think about all the
times where I really considered white
people my friends and then when we got
in a small argument they released all
the racism they hid throughout our whole
friendship
scary and then I think about the fact
that I became
what what does that mean
because that
that would be odd if you were friends
with somebody and then the moment you
had a little tiff over I don't know
um hey let's split the bill no I'll pick
up the bill or you had a little tiff
over I want to go see this movie no I
want to go see that movie they just
started saying you n-word you uh you put
on your clan hood or something like that
yeah I don't I don't
believe that has ever happened
now does she mean that when she and her
white alleged friends get into an
argument
uh the very fact of disagreeing is taken
to be racist because that's how the libs
argue today the libs argue today and
they say if you ever
just disagree with a black person you've
got to be racist if you ever disagree
with a transgender identifying person
you're a
transphobe if you ever disagree on any
topic if you disagree on the idea that a
man can become a woman you're you're a
phobic of some kind
I suspect that strongly
what is implied here keep going well
give them the opportunity to come clean
about any problematic past they say
nothing and then they get exposed for
being racist and it's never like some
low-key like I used to say the n-word in
songs no it's like n-word hard or
against black people
like like tell me why white people are
normalizing racist past
also I think about the fact that way
people have continuously when given the
opportunity oppressed multiple
marginalized communities and I think
about the fact how easy it is for them
to do it again like if they really want
to they would bring slavery back they
kind of already did with the criminal
justice system plus the rate of hate
crimes
I will legit always be scared of white
people until they're the minority
which I hope will be sooner than I think
so what is she going to do then
what if white people became the minority
and this woman wants
a an explicitly racial form of the
justice system
what happens to the white people when
that lady is in charge
you see the flaw in her argument of
course she says
that white people all they want to do is
oppress black people they're just so
oppressive that's why they have
affirmative action that's why they keep
pushing these crazy reparations policies
that's why they have all of these these
rules that that's why they don't when
BLM is riding around the country they
don't punish them at all but when a
Yokel and a granny show up to the
Capitol on January 6th they throw them
into solitary confinement because they
want to oppress the black people so much
if white people are the majority of the
country which This Woman's lamenting
then why aren't the white people doing
that now why aren't they bringing
slavery back now she has a little
parenthetical she says well they sort of
have through the criminal justice system
so she's saying if you punish criminals
you punish robbers and murderers and
killers
then your
that's the equivalent of slavery so
she's giving you a vision of the
Criminal Justice System under her
preferred world that would be a criminal
justice system in which white people
can't do anything right
in which the the jails are emptied
criminals are let off the hook
it would be a criminal justice system
that is explicit about punishing people
for their race we have a justice system
right now that that does actually punish
people for their race it punishes white
people and Asian people if they're the
wrong race
and those are the two wrong races then
they have a harder time getting into
college they have a harder time getting
jobs and if you're a part of a favorite
race then you have an easier time having
those things
and and
what this woman is saying is well once
I'm in power oh we're going to turn that
up to 11 baby I don't know that doesn't
seem great that doesn't seem like a
great idea now
I'm very sorry to say there won't be a
member block today Mr Davies has written
in my teleprompter that I should blame
producer Danny for this uh that doesn't
make a lot of sense that doesn't seem
like a rational reasonable thing to do I
will blame uh Mr Davies for that because
you know we are here in Washington DC we
did the Tim pool show last night it was
a lot of fun you can catch that over at
Tim's YouTube channel timcast IRL and
now Mr Davies is saying oh I've got to
get on an airplane right now so I've got
to pack up the whole studio in this in
this hotel room and I'm not allowed to
do the member block well okay
we need to figure out different flights
next time Mr Davies okay but there's so
much more that I want to get to I guess
we're just gonna have to hold that for
tomorrow at least I did get a Live
in-person member block yesterday with
some members of the creme de La Creme
who came out to Pitt we had a nice cigar
and a drink yesterday afternoon so
hopefully we'll be able to do that again
soon in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
thank you foreign